I have such a funny voice mail to play today.
As many of you know, we don't swear on the
David Pakman show.
Like sometimes there will be swears on my
youtube live streams because those are only
on youtube and swearing is okay, but because
the show is on nearly 200 radio and television
stations and a lot of these, most of them
are bound by FCC regulations.
We keep the show FCC safe because we don't
want to get our affiliate stations find in
any way.
Um, I got a call from a very sweet sounding
mom of a young David Pakman show view, or,
or presumed David Pakman show viewer who says
that her kid is picking up a lot of swearing
for me and from me.
And of course, I don't swear on the show.
I think that this mom has me mixed up with
Kyle Kalinsky of secular talk who swears like
a sailor.
Take a listen to this.
Yes.
Good evening Mr Pacman.
I am the mother of one of your subscribers.
He has a huge fan of yours, but unfortunately
he's imitating you a lot and swearing a lot.
Um, which is just I'm becoming for a young
man.
I wanted to ask you politely if you might
be able to just be aware that you have some
young listeners and not swear as much.
Um, thank you very much.
Bye Bye.
Yeah,
well we don't swear on the show.
Can't be me.
So, uh, I would check again with your son
whether he's picking up the scoring from me
or from Kyle Kalinsky or from somebody else.
But I think there is a case of mistaken identity
here.
It is definitely not me that is doing the
swearing.
Although he sounds like a great kid.
If he's watching progressive independent media,
we've got a great bonus feel for you today.
We will talk about the latest allegations
against Alex Jones.
They involve child porn insanely enough.
We will talk about the evolution of the eyes
of dogs to appeal to humans and our emotions.
And we will also talk about a confederate
monument in Nashville that has been vandalized
with the words they were racist.
It's anti racist vandalism against a confederate
monument, or as maybe someone like Alex Jones
might suggest.
Is it a false flag meant to make the anti
racists look bad?
All of those stories and more on today's bonus
show,
www.joinpacman.com to become a member and
get instant access to the award winning awards
we've created and given ourselves award winning